معنا من غزه الان وائل الدحدوح وائل لو
عدنا الى ما اعلنته سرايا القدس من نعي
لمسؤول المجلس عضو المجلس العسكري ومسؤول
وحده العمليات اياد الحسنه
هذا صحيح البيان صدر للتو من سرايا القدس
الجناح المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وفي
البيان كان بيانا مقتضبا لنعي هذا القائد
الكبير حسب وصف البيان اياد الحسني عضو
المجلس العسكري ومسؤول وحده العمليات فيها
وهو منصب من ارفع المناصب التي يتقلدها
شخصيه في في الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي هذا البيان ياتي ليضع النقاط على
الحروف ويسجل الستار على حاله الضبابيه
التي سادت خلال الساعات الماضيه
لاسباب كثيره حقيقه كان من بينها حسب
مشاهداتنا ومراقبتنا
للاستهداف المباشر الامر الذي حول
الجثمانين اللذين تم استخراجهما من الشقه
السكنيه المستهدفه الى اشلاء والجثامين
كانت محت متفحمه وبالتالي كثير من حاله
اللغط والشائعات والاسماء التي ترددت حول
هذا الامر اما وان هذا البيان صدر
فبالتاكيد الان اصبح الاسم معروف والمهمه
معروفه وبالتالي تطابقت المعلومات مع تلك
التي كانت اسرائيل قد اعلنت بانها استهدفت
هذا الشخص في هذه الشقه التي تشير اليه
الان اياد الحسني وائل نراها الان في هذه
الصور التي
نشرتها سرايا القدس
الحقيقه توجد صورتان صوره لصاحب اللحيه
البيضاء وصوره اخرى للشاب اصغر منه لا
ندري بالضبط ايهما بالضبط
الذي يعتمر القبعه اذا هو اياد الحسني
الذي نراه الان صاحب اللحيه البيضاء اذا
اتفضل وائل واصل
هذا صحيح هو صاحب اللحيه البيضاء
ويرتدي القبعه هو اياد الحسني
وحتى نضع النقاط على الحروف اكثر ونستطلع
موقف الجهاد الاسلامي من هذه القضيه
وغيرها في اطار هذا العدوان على قطاع غزه
معنا الناطق باسم حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
طارق سلمى يعطيك العافيه كيف تقيمون ما
يجري الان في ظل هذه الاعتداءات ويعني
سياسه الاغتيال التي توجت باغتيال شخصيه
كبيره وازنه مثل اياد الحسني حياكم الله
بالتاكيد ما زال العدوان والارهاب المنظم
من قبل العدو الصهيوني ضد قد ضد قاده
السرايا القدس والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
هذا العدوان ياتي من اجل تغيير المعادله
الا اننا نؤكد في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
بان اغتيال قاده سرايا القدس لن يغير في
المعادله التي فرضتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بالتاكيد الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه تؤكد حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وسرايا القدس بانها في
حرب مفتوحه مع العدو الصهيوني وسيدفع ثمن
هذه الجرائم وهذه الاغتيالات التي تمارس
على قاده سرايا القدس والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وشعبنا الفلسطيني اليوم
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مستمره في القتال
والجهاد ضد العدو اغتيال قاده سرايا القدس
واغتيال اعضاء المجلس العسكري لن يضعف
الحركه على العكس يزيد الحركه قوه واسرار
ومواصله هذا الطريق وبالدليل الميداني
عندما تطلق اليوم سرايا القدس رشقاتها
صاروخيه لتصل القدس لتؤكد على رمزيه القدس
ولتؤكد على وحده الساحات وهي رساله يجب
على العدو ان يفهمها جيدا لكن لكن يعني
هذه الاغتيال جاء عقب رشقه القدس من
الصواريخ وهي لا بانها ضربه موجعه لسرايا
القدس يعني بالتاكيد
العدو يريد اضعاف الحاله المعنويه لسرايا
القدس والتاثير من خلال اغتيال قاده سرايا
القدس الا اننا نؤكد في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بان سرايا القدس منظومه كامله
ومتكامله سرايا القدس تمتلك القوه
العسكريه والتصميم على مواجهه المعركه
مهما كلف الثمن وسرايا القدس اكدت على
وحده الساحات من خلال ضرب القدس لتؤكد
للعدو الصهيوني بان هذه الاغتيالات لن
تغير شيء في المعادله
السرايا مستمره في قتالها وهي ترسل رساله
للعدو الصهيوني بان ما يحدث في القدس ليس
بمعزل عن غزه وسرايا القدس تتابع وتؤكد
على ان القتال مستمر رغم هذه الاغتيالات
هي تواجه وبقوه واقتدار
الرساله ميدانيه للعدو الصهيوني بانها
ستقاتل لن تتردد لن تستسلم لن تلقي السلاح
وهي تخوض هذه المعركه ضمن قوه وتكتيك
واستراتيجيه واضحه لردع العدو الصهيوني
وافشال كل مخططاته وسياساته هل تريد ان
تقول بان هناك سيكون رد خلال الساعات
القادمه على هذه الاغتيال الجديد بالتاكيد
ما تحدثت به سرايا القدس من خلال تحديد
ساعه السفر لهذه المعركه مع العدو وارسلت
للعدو رساله انت تستطيع ان تبدا الحرب
ولكن لا تستطيع ان تنهي هذه الحرب كيف
تريد ولذلك سرايا القدس اليوم لديها
سيناريوهاتها وخياراتها ومداياتها
ومفاجاتها للعدو الصهيوني وهي من ستحدد
نهايه هذه المعركه وبالتاكيد الرد على
جريمه اغتيال القائد الكبير ابو ان الحسني
عضو المجلس العسكري ورئيس وحده العمليات
في سرايا القدس لن يمر مرور الكرام حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي تؤكد على اسقاط
مبدا الاغتيالات لقاده سرايا القدس
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه ونحن نؤكد يجب على
العدو وقف هذه السياسات سياسات الاغتيالات
ضد المناصريه القدس والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
اليوم المقاومه مستمره في نضالها وقتالها
وهي تؤكد وهي ترسم الخارطه الفلسطينيه
بصواريخ سرايا القدس تؤكد على ان الصراع
لن يستطيع الاحتلال حسم الصراع وبان
الجهاد مستمر حتى تحرير الارض واسقاط كل
هذه المخططات سرايا القدس ومن خلفها
الجماهير الفلسطينيه اليوم تؤكد بانها في
مواجهه مستمره ومفتوحه لا يمكن ان تلقي
السلاح ولا يمكن ان تتخلى عن هذا السلاح
الا بذكر العدو طبعا على ذكر سرايا القدس
والمقاومه يعني كثير من اللغات والضخ
الاعلامي الاسرائيلي حول من يقاتل على
الارض العدو يحاول ان يقول بان الحرب ضد
الجهاد الاسلامي هل هناك حقا وحده حال من
خلال غرفه العمليات المشتركه راينا
تصريحات كثيره على لسان رئيس المكتب
السياسي اسماعيل هنيه والناطقين باسم حماس
وحتى الناطقين باسم الجهاد يتحدثون عن ان
الغرفه وان الفعل المقاوم هو فعل جماعي هل
هذا حقا موجود على الارض نعم عندما خاض
سرايا القدس هذه المعركه كان هناك تنسيق
كامل ومشاورات على اعلى مستوى مع القوى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والابرع العسكريه
واكدت من خلال موقفها الموحد
الجهزيه التامه والكامله والمتكامله واكدت
الغرفه المشتركه بانها مستعده ومتاهبه
للرد على جرائم الاغتيالات وجرائم العدو
الصهيوني ضد الشعب الفلسطيني مهما كلف
الثمن نعم الجهاد الاسلامي وسرايا القدس
هي راس الحربه هي من تقاتل هي من تطلق
الصواريخ هي من
تواجه هذا العدو ولكن بموقف وطني فلسطيني
موحد واكدت على ذلك من خلال الوحده على
البندقيه وحده المعركه ووحده المصير ووحده
الشعب في مواجهه العدو الصهيوني سرايا
القدس حركه الجهاد الاسلامي تؤكد على وحده
الساحات من خلال الفعل الميداني تؤكد على
وحده الفصائل والوحده الفلسطينيه من خلال
وحده الموقف الفلسطيني ولذلك لا يمكن لهذا
الاحتلال ان يستفرد بفاصيل دون الاخر
سرايا القدس ردت على ذلك نعم هي من تقاتل
هي من تطلق صواريخ ولكن تطلق بحمايه وموقف
وطني فلسطيني
الجامع الاحتلال الصهيوني وايضا اكدت على
وحده الساحات بان المقاومه
مستمره في الضفه الفلسطينيه مشتعله
العمليات تتصاعد وفي اراضينا المحتله وغزه
اصبحت رافعه مهمه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
لتبث الامل في شبابنا الذي اصبح ينخرط
الان في الضفه الفلسطينيه واراضينا
المحتله ليؤكد على نهج المقاومه وصاوبيه
المقاومه وخيارات المقاومه والتاكيد على
وحده الساحات ولذلك العدو فشل فشلا كبيرا
في فصل الساحات في فصل التنظيمات عن بعضها
التي اكدت على وحده القضيه الفلسطينيه
وباننا شعب فلسطيني نقدم اغلى ما نملك
نقدم قاده الشعب الفلسطيني قاده السرايا
القدس من اجل الروايه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
هل هناك جهود مستمره فيما يتعلق بالتهدئه
هناك جهود حتى هذه اللحظه
ومباحثات ولكن نحن في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي لا تعليق حتى هذه اللحظه بقدر ما
نتحدث ميدانيا مع العدو الصهيوني شكرا
جزيلا استاذ طارق سلمي الناطق باسم حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وهو واقع الحال في قطاع
غزه حقيقه التصعيد مازال مستمر توج
بالاغتيال وسلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه
في مناطق مختلفه تم تدمير عدد من البيوت
خلال الساعتين او الساعات الثلاث الماضيه
في اكثر من مكان في قطاع غزه هناك اصابات
وصلت الى المشافي وبالتالي كانت هناك ايضا
في المقابل رشقات صاروخيه اطلقت وهو واقع
الحال الذي يمكن ان يمتد ليشمل اهدافا
ربما اكثر من ذلك